ils sont en première ligne pour assurer
le maintien de l'ordre tous les samedis
depuis deux mois ou pointé du doigt pour
des violences lors de ces affrontements
les policiers sont bien sûr tous les
fronts stéphane est l'un d'entre eux
plus de vingt ans de carrière deux
enfants il a participé à 10 samedi de
manifestation les heures supplémentaires
s'accumulent pour nécessité de service
il s'en montrent l agressivité et une
certaine usure
il ya une fatigue qui s'installe c'est
indéniable on est quand même m'entraîner
et puis on essaie de faire face on
essaie de trouver des temps pour se
reposer pour se reconditionner un petit
peu les enfants ils sont inquiets sont
peut-être pas toujours à même de
comprendre tout ce qui se passe donc on
essaye de ne pas trop leur en parlez pas
trop les impacts et non plus fini les
rassurer mais c'est pas toujours évident
toute la semaine et une montée en
tension vers le samedi alors que douze
policiers dijonnais ont déjà été blessés
lors des affrontements
en attendant de voir l'efficacité au nom
de la loi anti casseurs il assume
l'utilisation des lbc et autres
flashball
c'est une manière aussi de maintenir à
distance les manifestants et puis de
neutraliser certains éléments qui sont
vraiment violent qui lance tout un tas
de projectiles on a eu des boules on a
eu des
déroulement des billes d'acier ont serré
les frondes des locaux de l'acide d
extrêmement pour nous c'est une arme
intermédiaire qui est indispensable il
estime que sans ces armes il y aurait
encore plus d'affrontements directs et
deux blessés samedi il sera en tout cas
à nouveau sur le terrain